What are your thoughts on photodynamic therapy? Are you aware of anything we can do at home for instance
Blue Light Plus Curriculum and Cream has a sensitizing agent to treat skin cancer and breast tumors close to skin or is it too complex to do at home?
So photodynamic therapy is the problem with that is that is is a junk male term
Because we could say that you're doing photodynamic therapy
By doing exactly what you're saying you're using blue light or red light or green light therapy with the cream over
Treating a skin cancer. I would say I would say I absolutely do that at home something like that
But thinking that you're going to get a deep systemic change
other than skin
Deep changes with doing photodynamic therapy is questionable even in the realm
So technically when photodynamic therapy came out they were using lasers internally
To with a sense ties an agent to affect the breast tumor or something like that
And then there there's all sorts of
Companies that were making photodynamic therapy units that were simply very low level lasers
But that okay, if you're only doing a so lasers
are graded
at a
From a level one to a level four laser. So a level four laser is a very strong laser
And if you put a different head out of you can actually do surgery with a level four laser
But the level one laser would be almost to the level of a laser pointer
Or just using blue light therapy or red light therapy
As your photodynamic
Piece to the therapy now you're not going to have any benefit to that other than skin deep
But if you're trying to do something on the skin by all means do go for it
But if you think you're going to have effects deeper
You know even several millimeters deep to if your if a breast cancer was that close to the surface
um
You're not going to have effects now if the breast cancer was open and it was already at the surface now
You could have therapy doing that so by all means you don't do things that are topical like that